do you know what the round is it's the
thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video as you can see by the title of
the video I want to talk about the scene
where euron greyjoy kills Danny's dragon
Ragle the first thing I want to do is
ask all of you a question how many of
you think this was a setup by someone
who may be very close to Daenerys
Targaryen I know I did for some reason I
had this sense that someone sent word
that Dany and some of her men would be
arriving at Dragonstone at that exact
moment
now I do want to say this will not
necessarily be like one of my regular
Theory videos what I want to do is go
over some of the options of who could
have set Dany up then I was hoping all
of you could let me know who you think
did it if anyone at all let's take a
look at a short video from inside the
episode in case any of you were
wondering if maybe your own Greyjoy just
so happened to get lucky I want to show
you what one of the writers said about
that scene they do confirm that someone
let them know Danny was on her way
Qyburn went back to the drawing board
and he made even larger more powerful
scorpions dozens of them are now lining
the walls of King's Landing and dozens
more or melted on the decks that they
are in fleet while Dany kind of forgot
about the iron fleet and Euron's forces
they certainly haven't forgotten about
her and they're just waiting for her to
come back at this point they would have
gotten news that her army is emerged
victorious and we're gonna head south
and so they're just waiting an ambush
for her return so as you can see Cersei
found out when they would be coming down
to Dragonstone that's how you're on
Greyjoy knew exactly when to be there so
who could have possibly told them that
information is there someone inside a
Danny circle that would want to see her
get defeated or could it have been
someone else well the most obvious
answer would have to be Qyburn as we all
know he is the one that has access to
all the little birds and King's Landing
not only that but we also know he has
some connections in the north in the
very first episode of the season we saw
Qyburn tell Cersei about the night king
knocking down the wall and making his
way into Westeros
Khaybar most likely has little birds all
over the Seven Kingdoms the same way
Varys did so the obvious answer is
someone most likely like Qyburn know
when Danny and her men were leaving
white Harbor where all of Danny ships
were located once he knew when they
would be leaving white Harbor then he
could just estimate how long it would
take for them to get the dragon stone
all he would have to do then is tell
urine when he could expect them so he
could catch them all by surprise however
what if something a little more sinister
happened what if it wasn't Qyburn but
instead someone from Danny's inner
circle let's go back to the scene where
we saw most of the main characters and
Winterfell strategizing how they would
defeat Cersei Lannister we now know
there are a few characters in that scene
that do not want to see Danny claimed
the Iron Throne one of those characters
is Songza Stark now if you remember in
that scene Sean's and Daenerys had a big
disagreement over when they should send
their soldiers back into another battle
songs of one of their men to be able to
recover before they went down to King's
Landing but Danny wanted to go right
away
by the end of that scene Danny doesn't
get her way they are leaving Winterfell
almost immediately
now obviously Sansa was not very happy
about that look at the way she looks at
Danny right before the scene comes to an
end if looks could kill that's all I'm
gonna say we have won the Great War now
we will win the last one
in all seven kingdoms men will live
without fear and cruelty under their
rightful Queen
so as you can see Sansa knows exactly
when they're leaving and where they're
heading next songs also knows John is
traveling down the Kings Road to get
there so if Danny comes under attack she
doesn't have to worry about John getting
killed in the crossfire you also have to
remember where songs have got most of
her major influences from that would be
Cersei and Littlefinger we already know
Sansa does not like Dany whatsoever and
she does not want to see Daenerys on the
Iron Throne right after that scene is
over this is when Sansa finds out there
is someone that has a better claim now
Songza has no motivation to want to see
Danny gone forever that is the main
reason why songs a1a Tyrion to know
about Jon's claim this is something the
writers also talked about during the
inside the episode what will happen if
she gives Tyrion this information she's
a student of Littlefinger and she knows
how information travels and she can
think many steps ahead into the game the
way Littlefinger did and know that if
she tells Tyrion it's almost impossible
for Tyrion not to tell Varys and if you
tell I think these are all things that
have been occurring to Sansa between the
time we see her get that information and
the time she passes the message on
Tyrion Sansa is now actively trying to
get Daenerys out of the way
so do any of you think Sansa might have
sent a raven letting them know exactly
when Daenerys would be arriving at
Dragonstone all she would really have to
do is send an anonymous letter to almost
anyone in King's Landing now I do not
want to think Songza would do something
that sinister but it's very obvious
songs that does not want to see Daenerys
win the Iron Throne now let's look at
another option if it wasn't Sansa and it
wasn't Qyburn who else could have let
them know Danny was coming well maybe it
could have been Varys we already know he
is one sneaky son of a [ __ ] we also
know Varys does not want to see Danny on
the Iron Throne either and not only that
but Varys has already indicated he is
ready to see Daenerys assassinated who
knows how long Varys has been thinking
about that now let's look at his
reaction during that last council
meeting at Winterfell look at Varys his
face when Danny talks about how she
wants to attack King's Landing he saves
them so she will make sure they don't
believe it
it will hit her hard you'll rip her out
fruit and stem the objective here is to
remove [ __ ] without destroying King's
Landing that was the last thing varus
wanted to hear Daenerys say Varys might
be thinking in order for me to make sure
Danny doesn't burn down King's Landing I
either have to find a way to kill Danny
or killer dragons right before they
leave Winterfell this is when Sansa lets
Tyrion know about Jon's claim to the
Iron Throne now we don't see Tyrion and
Varys talking about that until they have
already set sail for Dragonstone that's
the first conversation we see them have
about Jon but that doesn't mean this is
when Varys found out for all we know
Tyrion could have told him at Winterfell
right after songs had told him then
waited until they were alone before they
started to discuss other options also
think about where Sansa was at when she
revealed that information
Sansa was standing outside that means
anyone could have overheard their
conversation about Jon there were
hundreds of workers and soldiers outside
at the time Songza was out there any one
of them could have heard songs in Tyrion
talking about John and Danny and who
knows how many of them could be working
for Varys like I said we already know
how sneaky he can be he might have
already sent out word before they left
for white Harbor you can already see how
much Varys has been working behind the
scenes look at all the letters right in
front of him he has been doing a lot of
communicating around Westeros Varys
obviously thinks they can win without
Dany's dragons that's why he doesn't
want to see Danny burn King's Landing
him and Tyrion think they can win
another way so it would not bother Varys
to help Cersei this one time it would
actually kill two birds with one stone
not only would that kill Danny and her
dragons which is what Varys wants anyway
but then Jon could go on and defeat
Cersei without running the risk of
Danny's Dragons burning down the city it
would be a win-win for Varys also if by
some crazy chance Cersei what happened
to win then it would also look like
Varys is on their side as well since he
would have helped them kill Danny and
the Dragons we all know this is the kind
of guy that Varys is he doesn't want
Cersei to win but if it's between Varys
living or
dying he would rather live that's why
he's been able to serve so many
different kings over the years now I
know you might be thinking varus cannot
have done that because he almost died in
the crossfire well if you go back and
look at that scene it did not look like
you're on and his men wanted to focus on
the ships at first all they wanted to do
was kill Danny and the Dragons it was
only when Danny got away that Euron got
that crazy look in his eyes to take out
the ships instead now do you think
you're on would give a [ __ ] about
killing Varys even if he did give them
that information I don't think so if you
have read the books than you know just
how big of a psycho your own Greyjoy
actually is hell we have even seen some
of it in the show he will go as far to
even murder his own family so he could
care less about someone like Varys even
if they were on the same side
Euron and Cersei are on the same side
and most fans think you're on will kill
Cersei so I would not count out that
option just because Varys almost died as
well he may have been given assurance
that only Dany and the Dragons would die
you also have to remember Varys and
Khyber and most likely know all the same
little birds I would not be shocked if
Varys and Qyburn were communicating the
whole time anyways like I said this is
not necessarily a theory video I only
wanted to talk about some of the options
because it did seem like Daenerys was
set up by someone on the inside but who
really knows we may never actually find
out let me know what you think either
way do you believe it was Qyburn
Sansa Varys or maybe someone else leave
your thoughts down below I want to thank
everyone for watching the video and
supporting the channel I hope you all
have a great day I'll see you again very
soon bye
you
[Music]
[Music]